I do want to update people on another one of
these anti vaccine trump people who is very
sick with covid. It's actually getting worse.
I don't like to hear this. I told you about
radio host Phil Vallentine. Phil Valentine
was a he says he was vaccine skeptical.
It's basically an anti backstroke. And pro Trump
guy told you earlier this week that he was very
sick with covid hospitalized and on oxygen. But
his family and the radio station where he works
made it a point to say he is not on a ventilator.
That has now changed. Phil Valentine is now on a
ventilator amid his covid-19 battle. Conservative
radio talk show host Phil Valentine, currently
hospitalized with covid, has now been placed on a
ventilator, according to a tweet from Nashville's
Supertech ninety nine seven WTN, the move to
the ventilator was made out of an abundance of
caution. The station's tweet goes on to say the
host made the decision to be put on a ventilator
to give his body some much needed rest.
Valentine had previously been on oxygen. Now,
in terms of the rest, I think when you're on
the ventilator, you're also sedated. So maybe
it maybe it's as much about that. I don't we just
don't know. It's sort of a cryptic way to say it.
The statement from the radio station states
they are confident he will pull through
and thank everyone for continued prayers. In a
July 11 Facebook post, Valentine confirmed he
tested positive for covid. He spoke about
his battle with the virus on his show.
I think I'm on the other side of it, he said as
he described coughing, congestion and fatigue.
That hurts like crap, he said. I'm certainly
moving forward, but not in a straight line.
Valentine previously expressed disagreement with
mask mandates, stating hospitals were never in
danger of being overwhelmed by covid patients.
That's a conspiracy theory. It's completely
untrue. He's been critical of the vaccine's
voicing concerns over safety. Mark Valentine,
Phil's brother, spoke with News two earlier
this week. At the time, he said Phil slightly
improved but said we haven't turned the corner to
recovery yet. He went on to say Valentine would
be the most pro vaccine person you've ever seen
when he returns. So, listen, it's good that Phil
Valentine is now a pro vaccine. I hope that
he recovers and is able to be a pro vaccine
advocate because he would be speaking to his anti
vax Tennessee audience. This is exactly the group
that needs to hear, hey, look at what happened
to me. Go and get yourself the vaccine. But this
is another cautionary tale. I take no pleasure in
the fact that Phil Valentine is now even sicker.
I'm hoping that he gets better. And part of
why I'm hoping it gets better is not because
I think he doesn't you know, it's not about not
resenting his anti-war activism. I resent it. But
if he does recover and becomes a vaccine advocate,
it could actually save lives because he's going to
be speaking to exactly the people who need to hear
it. We'll have more on this on our Instagram page.
Make sure you're following us, The David Pakman
Show, and follow us on tech talk. Yeah, can you
believe it? Almost fifty thousand followers
on tech talk. Also David Pakman show their.